[Music]
here in this video we will analyze the
big baddie of the fourth season of
stranger things this creature slash
monster is a very mysterious entity that
appeared out of the blue and was unknown
in the previous seasons but nevertheless
it is very powerful and a great villain
for the show so let's get to it so who
actually is wagner well the name is
actually taken from a character from the
game dungeons and dragons since the
nomenclature of the monsters in the show
is heavily based on the ones from that
board game this one too was named by
dustin in the series
from dnd wagner was a great human king
and a dark wizard or also called a lich
that ascended to godhood while he was
once considered the most powerful lich
to dwell on that world over the ages he
spent in undead wagner became feared
across the multiverse and was considered
the scourge of all civilizations
similarly in the show it was seen that
wagner was a very powerful dark entity
that shows up time after time to collect
the souls of his victims he was
mysterious and none but the victims have
seen what he looks like the other
characters are left in confusion as to
how he works and manages to kill the
kids to us beyond the fourth wall of
course we see him as a humanoid a
creature in shape with a body filled
with dark otherworldly tentacles and
tendrils growing out of his skin like an
armored skeleton but to the ones in
hawkins in the show he is unseen as he
works in the shadows and only makes his
presence known to the victims before he
snatches and kills them collecting their
souls for his growing power
so what are the real origins of wagner
well at first we all thought that he was
nothing but another small monster from
the upside down dimension nothing more
than a demogorgon level threat or
something under the influence or under
the control of the mind player but it
was quite the opposite
he is in fact the one who is control of
the other monsters most probably the one
behind the mind flayer as well so
essentially wagner is the main boss of
the upside down dimension
as of now
but he wasn't really from that place to
begin with wagner was a human male that
had tremendous psychic powers much like
11 he was the first of the children
tested for their powers he was called
number one and then later revealed to be
henry creel the son of victor creel
henry creel was a young kid who
discovered his laden powers when he and
his family moved into hawkins he was
disillusioned by normality and the way
his parents put up a facade of being
normal to other people while holding
dark secrets within themselves
so he killed his mother and sister while
framing and making his father believe
that it was a demon who did it he was
later transferred to the site where kids
were experimented on for their powers
and grew up there learning to control
and harness his abilities in the end
having a fight with 11 where she
defeated him and sent him to the upside
down the mansion and there he stayed
slowly growing into a grotesque monster
transformed by the environment and
gathering enough will and power to
return and plunge the world into
darkness
so that's the origin of wekner but what
about his anatomy design and biology
while henry creel was a normal human and
physical makeup his mind is something
else it had tremendous laden psychic and
telekinetic powers
when he was sent to the upside down by
eleven he stayed there and became an
ugly and terrifying monster this monster
now known as wagner is stopped and
deformed like an abomination towards
life itself
his body is humanoid in shape with two
arms and two legs and a torso with a
head but that's about as human as he
gets
his epidermal layer is filled with
tendrils and tentacles that wrap around
his body like overgrown tumorous roots
his face bears a skeletal appearance
with no visible hair on his head not
even ears or a nose his eyes are a pale
blue in color he kind of looks like
skeletor from
he-man or something of that sort mixed
with the likes of the swarm thing
one of his hands had overgrown claws
that he uses to pull the victims in a
trance and lift them up and drag out
their souls and life force but the most
peculiar part of his body is the ability
of him to control the tendrils in his
dimension and connect with them via his
back this allows him to be everywhere in
the upside down and sort of go into a
hibernation or a dormant state where he
still actively controls the other
monsters like the upside down bats the
demogorgons and maybe even the mind
flayer so now let's go to his powers the
powers of wagner well wagner has a
massive influence in the dark dimension
he can read minds
search for people mentally even in the
real world and even powerful kinetic
powers where he uses to throw rocks and
things in that dimension but his most
unique ability is him having his own
alternate dimension called the mindscape
where it is kind of like
the upside down separate from it but
nearly alike the mindscape contains no
life recognizable to humans instead
harboring its own unique biology and
ecosystem biological growths of various
kinds such as tendrils and fleshlight
membranes which are permeating and
covering most of the surface is there
instead of soil and all of that sort
that is seen in the real world it seems
like the upside down but it is much
darker colder and obscured by a crimson
fork while having continuous thunders
and lightning storms which are kind of
red and pink in color
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the minecube family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one
take care fam